Taylor Swift is a mastermind not only in
the recording studio but she's also got
some major baking chops too and it might
be Karma that I hate baking but for you
guys I'm going to pull off some
vigilante but I've got a question are
her famous chai sugar cookies sweet
nothings or do they taste like snow on
the beach let's find out half a cup of
butter uh half a cup of the big bad
canola oil granulated sugar half a cup
and a half a cup of peted sugar vanilla
egg so I got one chai tea bag she just
suggest like putting those spices right
in
one baking powder pour teaspoon of
salt
great wow they actually worked these are
delicious and I'm sure my boys will love
them but if they ask me to make them
again from scratch you're on your own
kit